there are widespread reports in in the
UK that Rishi sunak has won significant
concessions from the EU does it suit
everybody for it to appear as if this is
hard won by the UK because everybody
knows that Rishi sunak has a difficult
job getting this through Parliament you
will understand that there is
enough I'm going to tell you about the
way that the British press or any other
press is writing in anticipation of
anything there is or is not likely to be
announced after that meeting so let us
take to waiting patiently for the press
conference if there is one that the
president
may take part in this afternoon and I
would strongly encourage you to ask you
a question there